it's great to be here my name is
marielle this is my first time at
strange loop so it's been wild so far
so i'm really excited to be here with
you today and i'd like to start by
introducing myself
so i'm a particle physicist in my day
job
i'm a postdoctoral researcher at uh
berkeley lab right now in california
a lot of my job involves making plots
kind of like this one
analyzing data from the large hadron
collider at cern
this is the largest particle collider in
the world and arguably one of the
largest and most complicated machines
humans have ever built
so i love my work and my work involves
building custom machine learning tools
to help us better understand particles
such as the higgs boson that are
fundamental to the universe
but i'm actually here today because uh i
have an extensive background in the
performing arts so particularly in
contemporary theater and dance
and thanks to motion capture technology
i've been able over the past few years
to analyze my movements through the lens
of a scientist and kind of bring my
multiple loves together
so today i'm here as a performing artist
who has worked with machine learning for
a couple years and i hope to talk about
not only my research but also some of
the highlights and pitfalls of that
journey so far
and
basically this journey started in 2017
and since then i have led a couple of
independent research groups
working at the intersection of machine
learning and choreography
so probably a lot of this audience would
identify as creative types i was a mad i
would imagine in some form so you might
be familiar with a problem that i've
often faced when improvising in the
dance studio which is that i find myself
falling into a kind of creative rut
where i'm returning to the same ideas
over and over again
and this quote which is by one of my
favorite choreographers the late pena
bausch um really kind of summarizes it
uh
i wondered if some of the machine
learning techniques that i was working
with in my job as a particle physicist
could possibly apply to my art making
and help me to generate fresh new
movements that were nevertheless in my
own style
so i wasn't sure exactly how this would
turn out
i had a couple of goals as i got started
i wanted the generated movements to look
realistic you know like a like a human
being on earth preferably uh with forces
of friction and gravity present
i also wanted it to authentically look
like my own style what you know whatever
that meant to me i wanted it to be
movements that i probably would do in a
studio
and more than anything i was hoping for
movements that would surprise me and
inspire me to get up and moving which is
this final point obviously which is
kinetic desire that i just wanted
something that would give me that desire
to get up in a dance studio and move
so i should mention that the use of
technology and dance has a long and
interesting and rich history
in it's been spanning decades in uh the
history of modern post-modern and
contemporary dance so many prominent
choreographers in this discipline have
used algorithms equations games of
chance motion capture even and more to
generate work over the years
so in some ways what i'm presenting
today is nothing new
in other ways i would say though the
incorporation of neural networks in
particular and choreography is a
relatively recent phenomenon and it
feels very cool to be one of the people
who has been interested in pushing that
specific intersection forward over the
past few years
so when i started this project in 2017
there was some previous work in applying
neural networks to choreography so this
gives you a sense of the state of the
art at the time
so on the left is a project called core
rnn and on the right is a project that
was a collaboration between google arts
and culture and the choreographer wayne
mcgregor
so
both projects
kind of have a similar model for the
human body
with around 15 to 20 points representing
their motion
and both of them i would say had
some difficulties capturing full
three-dimensionality of a dancer's
movements the
project on the left used an xbox kinect
camera to detect a pose which is a
single camera facing front so if your
arm is occluded from the camera it's
difficult for the software to figure out
where your body is
and on the right uh they actually used
video archives of mcgregor's work and
extracted poses from those
two-dimensional video frames so it
suffered kind of the same difficulty
both of them also used sequential models
in machine learning that were designed
for time series predictions
so we can kind of contrast those with
the
the type of data that i was able to
extract using motion capture studio at
my phd institution that
used a multi-camera setup of 20
different
motion capture cameras so you can see
that it's really able to capture all the
kinds of rotational motion that i might
come up with in a studio
and i was also able to capture around 50
points on my body representing different
areas
and this multi-camera setup allowed for
nearly
gapless data taking so i could even
roll on the floor and it was able to
interpolate where some of the points on
my body needed to be at those points
so here's how we we collected that data
it's a it's the classic motion capture
suit with a bunch of ping pong balls
that are reflective all over my body um
so they're collecting xyz uh components
for each of the points on my body at
around 35 uh frames per second
so it's a pretty um high dimensional
data set um by some metrics and uh
so what i'll share with you today are
two different projects that i led with
different independent research groups
and uh together we kind of pioneered the
application of a couple different
architectures and machine learning to
motion capture of choreography so the
first project i'll talk about is a
variational autoencoder which is a vae
for short and then the second project is
a graph neural network or a gnn
um yeah and sorry i should say on the
bottom is the multi-camera setup where
you can see all the different camera
angles that were
viewing my movements
great so this first project is the
variational auto encoder and my research
team was composed of many different
types of experts
some
physicists who i collaborated with in my
particle physics work uh others who were
interested in the digital humanities and
also some
dance choreographers and researchers
and we worked together for a couple
years and then published our work in the
summer of 2019.
so the architecture that we designed is
a variational autoencoder
and an autoencoder is a kind of machine
learning architecture that tries to
generate an output that closely
replicates the inputs and the catch is
that often in these models there's an
information bottleneck that's built into
the architecture so here you can kind of
see this classic bow tie shape where the
innermost layer of the model is highly
reduced compared to the size of your
inputs and your outputs
and so after quite a lot of iteration
and training eventually the model should
find
an efficient
and lower dimensional representation of
your input in that latent dimension
and
moreover the model that we built is a
variational autoencoder which sort of
extends that basic autoencoder structure
to allow for sampling and for generation
of new material
so
rather than learning a specific point to
represent every input sequence that i
showed the model the model learns a
probability distribution for each of the
latent dimensions present in the system
and then i sample from those latent
probability distributions to then
generate new material
so here are some examples of randomly
sampling from the latent space of this
model so each of these movements are
fully generated
and you can see that i think in my view
they check the box of realism they
mostly look like humans existing on
earth there's some kind of interesting
artifacts and shaking sometimes but
i think for the most part it was able to
capture a lot of really nice
diverse and interesting movements even
though these might not be
necessarily the most exciting movements
that you could imagine doing in a dance
studio so i would say these are typical
movements of the latent space
but
what i was excited to try is to try
sampling from parts of the latent space
that were kind of on the fringes of the
actual manifold of my real data so sort
of the areas that had less coverage in
real data and see what some of the more
unusual movements that i could construct
would look like
so that process is exactly what i did to
construct the following video piece
which is also made up fully of
generative movements
[Music]
[Music]
all right i can't show the whole thing
unfortunately
so uh so that was an example of sort of
just working with the generated
animations of the outputs um i'm also
interested in live performance kind of
first and foremost so i've had a couple
um
experiences of trying to put those
generated movements back onto a human
body
so this was from a very early work in
progress of
having myself and a couple other dancers
respond live on stage to some generated
paths
generated by the model
and then also my collaborator raymond
who's a phenomenal dancer
did a performance in the motion capture
studio itself where our data was
collected
and that allowed him to get live
feedback from the model in the following
way
so projected on the screen
there are a couple different um
segments of what the model is responding
to so you can see his actual
motion capture points in the middle on
the right is kind of where along uh we
call it like the phi rotational axis so
it's rotation around z which angle he's
facing
and on the left is maybe the most
interesting which is where in the latent
space is his movement at any one time
and so as a dancer his prompt was to
play with staying in one area of the
latent space and trying to figure out
what movements belonged in that area
versus traversing far across the laden
space and trying to challenge the model
in that way
[Music]
so that was really fun um and that could
have been maybe the end of the story was
generating new material with this model
but we also found
another interesting way to put it to
good use so we found that beyond just
generating outputs this model was also
pretty good at creating variations on
existing phrases that i might find
interesting as a choreographer but might
want to tweak in some non-trivial way
so uh this is kind of a cartoon of what
this looks like but because the model
clusters related phrases together in the
latent space you can explore neighboring
sequences in this latent material and
then see how they uh how they align so
for example the top two phrases that
i've generated here um
both seem to share that they are on the
floor whereas these two movements on the
bottom kind of share this timing of
moving from uh crouch to standing so
there's kind of these interesting higher
dimensional relationships that are
shared between
these different sequences
so we can exploit this fact uh in a
really interesting way
so we can
look at the specific latent embedding of
a given sequence so in this case the
black sequence here represents it is my
actual motion capture data that we use
to train the model
whereas in blue we see the model's
generated
output representing this phrase
and you can see that the model's pretty
well trained because it's captured a lot
of the relevant kinematics that make
this sequence kind of unique
but now if i take this latent embedding
that the model has to represent this
input phrase and then i add a little bit
of noise to that original point so i
kind of deviate from the original point
and decode a new phrase that is nearby
then the result is that i get a new
movement that's very closely related to
the original sequence but has a
modification in this case it's at the
end of the sequence you can see that the
movement rotates a little bit
and you can imagine playing with this
quite a bit so
if you deviate even further
you get a movement that still is related
to the original kind of choreographic
intent of that phrase but deviates
even further
so it's a fascinating exercise to trace
how a single choreographic idea
you know translates into something else
as you move further and further from
that original point
it was using this procedure that around
last spring
at the onset of the pandemic i was able
to generate the following video
which is a duet with myself
so since i knew that i wasn't going to
be able to dance in person with someone
for a long time
it was something i was interested in
doing early on
at the time i thought that was going to
be maybe a few weeks and it ended up
being a bit longer than that
so next i'll show you an excerpt from a
video of this duet with myself
[Music]
[Applause]
so um so that sort of concludes the
first um you know arch of this effort
and uh the story continues a little bit
which is that uh this past summer i was
an intern in intel's ai group and i was
able to extend this work with a new set
of collaborators and uh
they had expertise ranging from
reinforcement learning to graph neural
networks uh to generic deep learning
so the motivations for this study were a
little different so rather than just
focusing on generating new material in
the best way that we could i was
interested in turning the analysis
inward and understanding relationships
between different parts of my body while
i danced and this was exciting to me
because this is actually what i think
about when i dance is how does my head
relate to my feet you know how is how
are my muscles reacting to certain
inputs so i was curious to see what a
machine learning model might tell me
about some of those important
relationships and whether they would
necessarily align with the way that i
actually feel like my body interacts
with itself as i move
so technically what that ended up
resulting in is modifying the latent
embedding of each given sequence to
include an explicit graph structure
representing each relationship between
parts of my body while i moved so
essentially it was a graph based
variational autoencoder
and graph neural networks as a theme are
neural networks designed to operate on
graph structures where a graph here is a
collection of nodes and edges where
edges represent relationships between
those nodes
so then in the neural network structure
those features associated with each of
the nodes and edges are then updated
periodically by aggregating information
from local subgraphs or neighborhoods
near those points
the structure of the model was based on
this project called nri or neural
relational inference which is a project
by thomas kipp max welling and quite a
few others
and the idea of this is to learn a
latent interaction graph to describe a
dynamical system of interacting
particles where you might not
necessarily know all of the
interactions that are happening
so in in this case for example in this
sort of toy model of a couple particles
that are orbiting each other
you have each pairwise particle
relationship assigned as one of some
number of edge types where edge types
kind of means what's the quality of the
interaction between these two particles
and that can include no edge meaning
that there's no relationship between
those types
so
excuse me our model as in nri
includes a graph neural network based
encoder and decoder and the encoder's
job is basically to output probability
distributions for each of the edges that
are present so i i input the same raw
data that i used to train the
variational auto encoder that i showed
you guys previously but in this case i
connect each of those points to every
other point so the model sees a fully
connected input graph as its input
and then the encoder's job is to
output a probability distribution for
each of those edges about whether that
edge belongs to edge type 0 edge type 1
edge type 2 edge type 3 in this case i
chose 4 edge types
and then the decoder's job is to
once we sample from those probability
distributions and get a discrete label
for each of those edges
the decoder takes in those edge
categorizations and then predicts the
future kinematics of the system
so i'll show you some highlights of some
of the relationships that the model
learned
so
in this case edge type 0 which is on the
left in pink i've been coded to mean no
interaction and i've actually also
imposed a prior distribution onto these
uh different edge types such that ninety
percent of the edges should be
categorized as edge type zero so i've
asked the model to really be kind of
sparse
in the edges that it ends up
highlighting for the actual kinematics
of the system in hopes of making it a
little easier to interpret so most of
the edges are categorized
as no interaction and you can kind of
see that all of these i've highlighted
the top one percent of the edges that
are kind of most representative of each
edge the most representative edge types
of edge type zero um to me don't really
tell clear story which makes sense
but of the following three different
edge types they picked up on some
interesting relationships
one that i found really exciting was in
blue with edge type two
so each of these edges that are most
representative of this type of
interaction originate in my right hand
and then travel down to my left foot
and given that i have a background in
ballet training we talk quite a bit in
ballet about opposition of arms and feet
and i'm also right-handed i don't know
whether to read into that or not but it
makes sense to me that my right hand
would be pretty articulate and then also
the way that my hand moves affects the
opposite leg in my body and then there's
also edge type 1 and edge type 3 that
also describe
relationships that all originate from
kind of one localized area of my body
and then those have ripple effects that
dictate movements in a very distant part
of my body so edge type one all of these
edges originate in my left hand and then
connect to my upper torso
whereas edge type three these edges
originate in my left foot and then
extend up to both of my hands
so i found it really interesting that
the model was picking up on these
relationships that i might not have been
able to write down based on my dance
training but that feel very
authentically true to the way that i
move
so we published this work uh last winter
in the nurbs workshop on machine
learning for creativity and design
i wish i had videos to show you of what
performances with this work looks like
but i haven't had access to dancers or a
dance studio for a number of years
because of this pandemic
so instead i did what any creator might
do in this instance which was make a
tick tock account and
i was locked in my house basically so i
was writing my thesis and then as i was
taking breaks on writing my thesis i
would get up and try to improvise using
prompts from this model
so i have a couple clips of what that
looked like
so on the left i have a prompt from a
highly ranked connection from the model
and in this case that's a connection
from the top of my head to my wrist my
right wrist
uh and so according to the model this
was a really important uh relationship
to think about in generating my future
movements and i found that as an
improvisational prompt it was pretty
useful it was um
yeah playful generative i feel like i
was having a lot of fun and thinking of
movements that felt good
then on the right i tried a really lowly
ranked connection so this was a
relationship between my left toe and my
left knee
which there's a bone connecting those
it's really hard to play with that
relationship
so i sort of interpreted it more broadly
as relationships between feet and knees
so i was playing with these really
awkward weird feeling movements
so anecdotally i felt like playing with
these really got me out of my comfort
zone and how i was thinking about
creating some new work
all right so last i'll just show a
couple slides kind of summarizing what
i've learned so far
in this process
so the first is that
i really thought that this process was
going to have a single output which was
generating new sequences
and it had that but i feel like it also
had this kind of diverse array of uses
that surprised me
so
some of those uses beyond just inventing
new material were kind of in the
co-creative space of creating a dialogue
with a model iterating on that dialogue
and seeing how it might respond
and that involves creating these
variations on existing sequences or even
getting live feedback from the motion
capture model in the studio
another aspect that i haven't really
talked about yet is a sense of
preservation
the dance world does not have a
universal written language to record
movement or to even talk about movement
and so it's kind of difficult to think
about how to preserve your creative
practice as a dancer
videos exist but videos are often of
performances that are just one instance
of the thing and it's not really
capturing the real thing
so i've kind of come to think of these
models as a way of preserving my
creativity in this body that i have now
as a way of potentially being able to
continue to invent with my creative
practice right now far into the future
and
even though i haven't applied this yet
maybe there's a potential to apply this
to historical documentation for other
choreographers choreographers practices
as well
i've also learned that glitches are so
awesome and appealing
i did not expect to be so
[Laughter]
i did not expect to be so delighted by
under-trained models or you know weird
failure modes
so they can be hilarious
um i've also found that they can just be
beautiful
you know ways that it can create these
imageries that i could imagine trying to
code for hours and hours
so they've been totally surprising in
that aspect also
and then
lastly um it's also taught me a couple
different ways of conceiving of my
relationship with a machine learning
model in a creative context
and that kind of relationship was
constantly shifting and so that's kind
of what i wanted to leave you guys with
today
so this is just my personal like mental
map um of how i've started to think
about this relationship so here the
y-axis kind of represents who has the
creative power or the autonomy in this
in this system is the model making those
creative choices or am i making those
creative choices
and then along the x-axis i have is the
model your friend or is the model not
your friend uh whatever that might mean
and i i feel like this model this
project has spent some time in kind of
each of these quadrants throughout its
evolution
it's ranged from you know automating in
the sense of just generating new
material and that's kind of the final
result
to uh generating like a mountain of
sequences and then i can kind of cherry
pick which phrases seem interesting to
me and then i craft a video piece out of
those outputs
um
it's also served as kind of like an
external eye critiquing my practice and
showing me what it sees in the way that
i move
sort of like an alien looking at my
movements
and then at times it has felt like it's
having its own creative experience it's
responding to my movements and it's
creating a relationship between my
previous movements and the current
existence of that model
so
all of all of these i think in the
future i'm kind of most excited about
this bottom left quadrant
and in particular i'm trying to pursue
creating models that are antagonistic
and kind of designed to challenge me
and maybe make me uncomfortable uh
because i think that sometimes the best
antidote to a creative rut is working
with someone who pushes you to do things
that you never imagined you could
so thanks so much for your attention
first of all great job nailing a strange
loop talk this is the most strange loop
talk i've ever been
fantastic
uh
and i guess
this is you know i don't know anything
about
training models but uh do would you
would you think that training
um on like ballroom or something more
structured with like rigorous rules do
you think the computer would have an
easier time with that or it would just
be super boring because it's so
structured
it's such a cool question thank you for
that um
yeah because i've really trained on just
myself as as an input and uh my
background is mostly in like western
ballet modern post-modern kind of kind
of movement styles and it's i think one
natural next extension would be applying
to yeah whether it's ballroom or indian
classical dance or other movement styles
that have uh
maybe a more codified
movement language it would be really
interesting to see what that looks like
i have no idea what it would look like
in this model
maybe one of the reasons why it's so
interesting to explore this space is
that
of the 256 dimensions in my latent space
i'm not really sure what any of those
dimensions really represent and maybe
with a more codified movement structure
you could actually start labeling some
of those dimensions that would be really
cool to see thank you
hey um yeah i want to echo that's such a
cool talk um
so
in the in the graph encoding it seems
like it found like correlations between
different parts of your body uh
in either one of those encodings were
you ever able to find like i don't know
parts of the sub manifold that
represented like were actually movements
isolated to one arm that were like local
to each other
in the graph representation if that
makes sense yeah
there are a couple instances where it
really fixated on feet um like one edge
type was just a single foot and all of
the connections within that foot and i
think it kind of depended on
what part of the movement data set it
was looking at and where the
articulation was going on
i did expect it to to pick up more on
skeletal structure i thought maybe you
would only find like skeletal
relationships
that was one of the inputs to the graph
model is each edge was labeled with a
zero or one based on whether or not it
belonged to what i described as the
skeleton so it had a little bit of that
information already um
but yeah for the most part i felt like
it picked up on these like crossbody and
only a minority of the edge types were
really located in one single area
thanks
first up great talk
you mentioned the use of this
research for preservation right
any words on what others other dancers
are not familiar with machine learning
or
data
representation in general i mean any any
thoughts on how this can be made more
general purpose for
non-engineers
yeah it's an interesting question
because when i when i talk about this
work to
technology or science people
people seem to be really interested in
it when i talk with choreographers and
dancers by and large people are kind of
like
why
we have existing practices in the dance
world to kind of you know
preserve someone's legacy and someone's
ideas and
those can't be captured in a machine
learning model like this they're
captured in language and in
relationships and
when i've learned pieces that are from
choreographers it's often taught by
someone who has already performed that
piece or someone who trained in their
company and there's kind of this oral
history that's really valued in the
field so i think it's personal it it
works for me because it feels like it
authentically captures some part of my
process but
um that might not be true for most
choreographers but i wonder how that
might extend to other creative types who
also have this like technology bent and
maybe it'll be useful in that sense too
um
do you think this could be used for
something like measuring the
effectiveness of that oral history
like if you can capture movement now and
in 20 years see if we're playing a game
of telephone with how we're
capturing
the history
yeah interesting i mean we definitely
are um
i i did a piece a few years ago where we
were learning from the piece hadn't been
performed in like 40 years we were
learning from these black and white
video pieces with no audio or like the
audio had been like um you know damaged
in some way so it was out of sync so
like kind of by construction i think
every new iteration of a dance piece you
can't perfectly capture it um
but to your question i think one way
that i didn't put on this bullet point
list is
i think it could possibly be used for
like teaching choreography um in kind of
like a gamified structure like here's
the latent path of my choreograph
choreography now you have to try to
match that as best as you can so you
know to the extent that you want to
measure correctness of choreography
you might you may or may not be
interested in that but i could imagine
applying it in that kind of structure to
share your material with someone
else hey so first up great talk
um
i
there's one
video example in here but i'm
particularly curious about which first
of all disclaimer i don't know much
about vaes it was from that first half
of the presentation but i'm just trying
to wrap my head around how exactly
the input space maps to the output space
in that um
that one example you showed where there
was a choreographer
and there was a live feed of where their
current movements were in the in the
latent space
i'm just curious
when we're looking at that that like
two-dimensional representation of where
they currently were in the latent space
is that just a function of
their current position as in you know
regardless of what they've done five
seconds ago if they were in the same
pose now they'd be in that same spot in
the latent space now or is the
distribution over something more like a
stochastic process wherein yeah
the exact thing he did 10 seconds ago
would have affected his position now
even if you were in the same position
now in two different scenarios yeah
totally um
so the performance with raymond i'm
trying to remember it may actually have
been
a pose space like a space of poses
rather than sequences
in which case it was responding to you
know at a given frame of time
what does that correspond to in the
model and so that might have had better
inference um for the purposes of his
work where maybe waiting five seconds to
uh to get each movement sequence and
then getting input from the model
wouldn't give him enough time so we
played around with both models we had
kind of the sequence based model which
is what i used for most of this talk but
we also have a model of just poses and
so you can imagine tracing any line
through the latent space there and then
constructing a sequence of those poses
um but yeah we we loaded the trained
model into like a tensorflow.js system
and we were able to kind of ping that in
real time with the motion capture suit
so in the video that we're looking at um
it looks like you'd or it's generated
based off of like you had planted one
foot and then pivoted on the ball of the
foot but based on the way that the space
is recorded
it looks like it's always
centered at zero zero
do you think that um the lack of
absolute positioning
kind of confused it in that it sort of
thought hey it's fine mariel can just
arbitrarily start spinning in place
um like do you do you think it could
become more robust with absolute
positioning or absolute offsetting
possibly yeah it was one of the
pre-processing steps that we included to
let the model focus on just the body's
position was kind of averaging out xy
positions in in the overall data set so
it sort of looked like i was on a
treadmill in all directions um
and i found that that was useful just
for getting better results for the
actual generated sequences but um but
it's it does have this interesting side
effect of looking like i'm ice skating
or something like there's very little
friction at times in the generated
outputs and that's probably a result of
some of the pre-processing that we
applied
okay thank you so much that was a great
talk thanks guys
[Music]
you